Oh Leute, heute gucken wir uns Jubantu 23.10 an. Ich habe nämlich gesehen, dass das vor
drei Tagen rausgekommen ist. Und es wurde erstmal, lustigerweise habe ich so noch nie
erlebt oder noch nie gelesen, wieder zurückgezogen. Habt ihr das mitbekommen? Es wurde released
und dann wurde es wieder gelöscht. Oder gelöscht ist das falsche Wort, wieder reverted. Nein,
LTS. LTS kann man sich ganz einfach merken. LTS ist immer in den geraden Jahren. Also
merkt ihr einfach, gerade Jahre sind, also gerade Jahre und 04 sind immer, sind die LTS. Also
2004, 2002, 04. Erstes Halbjahr, gerade Jahre sind LTS. Das ist quasi alle zwei Jahre. 2004,
2002, 04. Davor aber 1804. Tatsächlich, ja ist das so. Also, ja genau, also Ubuntu wurde,
Ubuntu 23.10 wurde zurückgezogen. Ne, ich glaube wegen ukrainischen Fake-Übersetzungen,
wo irgendwelchen, ja ich habe mir keine Übersetzung angeguckt, wo irgendwelche fragwürdigen Sachen
auf Kurillisch drin standen, hat irgendjemand getrollt bei den, bei den Translations. Und da
kann man jetzt Ubuntu selbst wenig Vorwürfe machen, die ziehen sich das auch nur aus irgendeinem
Web-Translate-Projekt. Haben es halt zu spät gemerkt. Ich meine so Übersetzungen mal alles
zu checken ist tatsächlich nicht so easy. Leute sind natürlich wieder überall voll
ausgeflippt. Ich habe mir das auf, auf Twitter durchgelesen. Ich nenne es trotzdem Twitter,
auch wenn es jetzt eigentlich X ist. Also nach dem Motto, wie kann das passieren? Checkt niemand
die Übersetzung. Ubuntu muss responsible sein. Dafür sind wir komplett ausgerastet. Die haben
das einzig Sinnvolle gemacht, was sie machen konnten und das auch relativ schnell. Sie haben
das erstmal zurückgezogen, bis es entfernt wurde und haben es wieder released. Fertig. Meine Güte,
die tun immer so, als sind sie alle unfehlbar. Gerade auf Twitter, die Leute. Ich weiß nicht,
was mit denen los ist. Und es waren glaube ich nicht nur, nicht nur anti-ukrainische Sachen
auf Kurillisch, sondern auch anti-Israel-Zeug in den Übersetzungen drin. Wie gesagt, ich habe es
nicht durchgelesen. Sie haben schnell reagiert, sie haben es rausgeschmissen. Also was wollen sie
alle? Genau, hinterher sind sie alle immer schlauer. Ich meine, die können sich gar nicht
vorstellen, wie viel sie kontrollieren müssten, wenn sie wirklich jedes einzelne Zeichen von
jeder Software, die sie irgendwie packagen für dieses US. Okay, in dem Fall könnte man sagen,
es war der Installer. Das heißt, der Installer könnte noch... Aber trotzdem. Sie haben schnell
richtig reagiert, zackig und jetzt ist es wieder da und dann ist auch alles. Irgendwann ist es auch
mal wieder gut, ja? So, Sekunde, Leute. Machen wir mal irgendwas anderes. Wupp, wupp, wupp. Wupp,
wupp, wupp. Wupp, wupp, wupp ist zu laut. Alter, wupp, wupp, wupp ist auf 20%. Teilweise schon
pp-iger Abmischung, oder? Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp. Ja, sowas mit Lautstärke. Ja, ich verstehe es
auch nicht so genau. Zumal die Sachen ja nicht direkt über Ubuntu committed wurden, sondern wo
das irgend so ein Web-Translation-Projekt gepullt wurde. Also, mich wundert es ehrlich gesagt,
dass es nicht schon früher mal irgendwo passiert ist. Ich denke jetzt, also ich vermute mal,
sie werden bei problematischen Sprachen zur Zeit, also die problematischen Sprachen bei der aktuellen
Weltsituation, werden sie jetzt ein bisschen genauer hingucken, also irgendwas jetzt auf
Arabisch oder irgendwas auf Kurillisch oder so, oder irgendwas auf Chinesisch. Wer weiß,
was da noch, was da alles ist. Aber das Ding ist halt, du kannst das, du könntest das am besten
wahrscheinlich sogar automatisiert testen, weil die Entwickler, die da reingucken, die verstehen
das ja nicht. Das heißt, die müssten es eh auch maschinell übersetzen und dementsprechend kannst
du das auch automatisch machen. Da gibt es bestimmt irgendeine AI für, so fasse mir diesen Text
zusammen, enthält dieser Text Beleidigung. Dann hat man schon mal zumindest ein bisschen was. Ich
muss mal kurz, bevor wir anfangen, ich muss mal meine Arch-Linux-VM starten und Package-Updates
machen. Ja. Moin, IlenikGuy, ein Grieche, vermute ich jetzt einfach mal. Es gibt ja kaum Updates.
Habe ich letztens schon geupdated? Ich glaube, ich habe letztens schon geupdated, weil das ist
für Rolling Release Arch, by the way. Oh, neue Firmware. Hoffentlich backt es nicht wieder in
der VM rum. Okay, jetzt bin ich gespannt. Laggt die VM jetzt nach dem Reboot und dem neuen Kernel
oder laggt sie nicht? Ja, müssen wir mal checken. Ja, ich sehe schon, es laggt nichts. Wir machen
gleich nochmal den Ultimativ-Lagging-Test. Aber ich merke das gleich. Warum nicht VM? VM ist das
Beste. Das ist aber übrigens noch nicht Ubuntu. Saat schon Silver, danke für den Sub. So, jetzt
lasst mal kurz checken. Da laggt nichts. Okay, Lag-Test bestanden. Also, es gab einen Bug vor
zwei, drei Kernel-Versionen in Verbindung mit VMware. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob es diesen Bug
irgendwie offiziell mal unter dieser Bezeichnung gab, aber ich habe es gemerkt, dass der Input in
VMware alle fünf bis zehn Sekunden kurz gestockt hat. Das war eigentlich gar nicht richtig zu
benutzen. So, jetzt ist gut. Jetzt passiert hier nichts. Nice. Leute, bevor wir anfangen,
ich kann mir übrigens schon mal das ISO downloaden. Ja, wenn ich jetzt noch richtig
schreiben könnte, wäre natürlich auch extreme-bug. So, Releases. Hatten die nicht einfach mal,
hatten die nicht irgendwie eine offizielle Seite, wo es so ein Download-Get-To. Ja,
wir müssen uns erst einmal angucken, was es für Neuigkeiten gibt, weil ich wette mit euch,
ich verpasse die Hälfte. Legacy. Ach, es gibt ja einen neuen Installer. Stimmt,
der wahrscheinlich genauso aussieht wie der alte, aber es gehört ja zum guten Ton,
ab und zu mal sein Installer-Framework zu wechseln, alle drei, vier Jahre. If it doesn't
download. Doch, doch, doch. Es downloadet doch. Okay, Jubantu ist am Downloaden. Wir müssen uns
mal kurz gucken. Ubuntu 23.10. What's new? Improved security. Also, mich interessieren zwei
Sachen. Mich interessieren, ob die wieder noch mehr Packages unnötigerweise zu sinnlosen Snaps
gemacht haben, dass ich dann einfach kacken kann, kack waiten und leaven. Und was die am
Server-Image geändert haben, beziehungsweise was da sonst drin ist. Ob da irgendwie, ob sie
vielleicht, ob sie vielleicht, ich glaube es ja nicht, ich glaube es ja nicht, aber Bean Beef,
danke für den Sub, ob sie vielleicht NetPlan rausgeschmissen haben. Aber ich glaube nicht,
dass sie NetPlan rausschmeißen, weil aus irgendwelchen Gründen mögen die NetPlan.
Ich kenn, sag mal, kennt ihr irgendeine andere Distribution außer Ubuntu, die diesen Scheiß
verwendet? Wer das nicht kennt, wer das nicht kennt, NetPlan ist ein Tool, wo man seine YAML
Konfiguration, wo man in einer YAML Konfiguration seine Netzwerkkonfig anlegt. Warum auch immer man
das machen soll. Als wären ifup, ifdown oder etc. Network Interface nicht gut gewesen. Was?
Meinung zu Kriegerstatement über dich. Was? Wer, wer Statement, Statementet was? Der Krieger,
warum sollte er über mich irgendwas Statementen? Also nicht, dass wir viel miteinander zu tun
gehabt hätten in letzter Zeit, aber weder ich noch er machen auf YouTube jetzt sonderlich viel.
Ist das G-Bait? Ja, das G-Bait, da gibt's überhaupt nix. Huge G-Bait, Lucky. Naja,
das ist deren Tool, die hänge immer. Ja, ich verstehe es auch nicht, was mit denen los ist,
Alter. NetPlan ist so ein Shit. So ein Schrott, Mann. Das ist richtiges Cackweight,
NetPlan. Massive Cackweight. Timeout direkt. Nee, Quatsch. Wozu? So, ist der Download fertig?
Ja, nice. Ja, ansonsten, ich weiß nicht. Ich erwarte von Ubuntu ehrlich gesagt gar nix. Also
das soll jetzt nicht schlecht sein. Also ich erwarte von denen jetzt nix, dass sich großartig
grundlegend da was ändert. Die sind eigentlich eines der so, ja, so der etabliertesten Distribution,
die es gibt. Ich habe früher total geschworen auf Ubuntu, also wohlgemerkt auf dem Server. Desktop
mäßig, Desktop mäßig habe ich schon ewig kein Ubuntu mehr benutzt, aber Server mäßig habe ich
jahrelang jetzt Ubuntu benutzt. Auch hier, wo ich schon gestreamt habe auf Twitch und so,
ich war ein Riesenverfechter von Ubuntu, habe gesagt Ubuntu, beste für alle Server direkt.
Ubuntu macht in gewisser Weise auch Sinn, gerade wenn man in irgendwelchen Cloud-Umgebungen
unterwegs ist. Da ist ja Ubuntu deutlich beliebter als Red Hat, was man ja auch verstehen kann. Ich
wäre auch froh, wenn wir gar kein Red Hat Shit mehr irgendwo hätten, aber gut, ist halt so. Zumindest
ich bin jetzt ein bisschen weggekommen von Ubuntu die letzten Jahre, weil die ganz komische Dinger
gemacht haben, weil die erst mit NetPlan angefangen haben, dann immer mehr Sachen in
den Snap gepackt und ich bin jemand, der auch mal ganz gerne beispielsweise ein X-Forwarding von
einem Firefox macht oder sowas, wenn man es braucht. Es kommt ja manchmal vor, dass man auf
irgendwelche Kisten um drei Ecken zugreifen muss und dann ist man für ein X-Forwarding von einem
Firefox ganz praktisch, aber das geht ja alles nicht mehr seit dem Snap ist und NetPlan mochte
ich noch nie. Ja, und jetzt bin ich mittlerweile auch bei Debian. Ich benutze eigentlich mittlerweile
defaultmäßig auch nur noch Debian auf meinen Serverkisten. Auf der Arbeit ist es ja leider
der rote Hut, Rotkäppchen sozusagen auf der Arbeit. Aber gut, wenn man gerne hunderttausende
für Lizenzgebühren ausgibt, beziehungsweise innerliche Lizenzen sind ja Support-Lizenzen
und meinetwegen soll mir recht sein. Alle deine Server sind Arch-Linux. Ja, das ist jetzt auch
nicht die allerschlauste Idee, aber wenn es dir gefällt, also ich glaube es dir ja nicht,
glaube ja auch, dass es ein leichter Cheat-Bait ist, aber es soll ja Leute geben, die das machen.
Verstehen tue ich es aber nicht. Bringt Red Hat einem so viel gegenüber Debian oder so? Dir
persönlich für eine eigene Kiste? Nee, gar nicht. Dann ist ein Debian deutlich angenehmer als ein
Red Hat. Red Hat ist Cack-Business ist das. Aber ist das Cack-Business-Bild weg? Wo ist das
Cack-Business-Bild, Leute? Wo ist das Cack-Business-Bild? Ist es weg? Ja, wir haben nur
noch Wupp-Wupp-Business. Wir hatten doch mal so ein schönes Cack-Business-Bild. Entdecken Sie die
witzige Bedeutung Cack-W? LOL. Alter, wenn ich solche sinnlos Click-Farming-Seiten sehe. Ja,
Cack-W-Business. LOL. Vor allem auch noch LOL. LUL würde ich mir noch gefallen lassen. Das wäre
dann, das wäre halt Cack-W versus LUL-W. Rofl-Copter. Wie konfiguriert ihr auf der
Arma die Linux-Forums? Ansible-Tower. Kommt drauf an. Also cloud-technisch ist das glücklicherweise
alles mehr oder ziemlich minimalistisch. Da ist übrigens auch Ubuntu und nicht Red Hat. Da ist
das alles minimalistisch und ziemlich self-contained und gezackig. Aber der Rest ist Ansible. Ja,
der Rest ist Ansible. Und leider habe ich, ich habe gelernt, dass Ansible anscheinend oder wir
sind unfähig dazu. Das kann auch sein. Das kann das sein, dass Ansible keine gescheite
Modul-Versionierung oder wie heißt denn das? Heißt das überhaupt Modul bei Ansible? Ich meine
nicht Playbook. Custom, Custom-Ansible-Module. Heißt das Module? Ne, das heißt doch bei Ansible
irgendwie anders, oder? Bei Terraform heißt das Module. Wie heißt denn das bei Ansible? Ne,
ist noch nicht vorbei. Egal. Zumindest kann das sein, dass die keine Modul-Versionierung können
oder wir sind einfach zu blöd. Das kann natürlich auch sein. Schließt mich ja mit eid. Aber
irgendwie haben sie immer wieder Probleme, dass Leute Server aufbauen und dann geht irgendwas
nicht, weil irgendwie einer an irgendeinem Ansible-Modul rumgewurschtelt hat. So,
also was brauchen wir denn hier? I will install the operating system later. Yes,
Linux. Jubantu. Ne, ne, ne, ne. Jubantu 64-bit. Wie sieht denn so mein Festplattenspeicher aus?
This PC. Oh, es wird aber immer enger hier. Ja, aber für die VM sollte es reichen. Machen wir
das gleich. Machen wir das hier gleich auf C und danach wird es wieder gelöscht. 4 CPU-Kerne,
CAC-Memory 16G. Ja, wenn schon. Also komm, Leute. Irgendwohin muss mein RAM. 27 von 64,
also zack, 16G. Use NAT-Interface, das da, das da. Create new virtual disk, single file. Da
kommen wir nicht weit mit. 40G. Jubantu. So, Drucker raus. Soundkarte kann meinetwegen dran
bleiben. Display. Ja, geht glaube ich alles in Ordnung, falls ich nicht irgendwas vergessen
habe. So, Jubantu. Zeige ich mal hier. ISO-Image. Downloads. Oh, ich hoffe, das ist fertig
mittlerweile. Ich muss mal kurz im Browser gucken. Ja, ist durch. So, also, während das jetzt
installiert, lesen wir uns mal durch, was es für Neuerungen gibt. Ja, ja, ich habe finish,
finish geinstallt. Stretch. Also, lasst uns doch mal kurz gucken, was sagen die denn? Was
es hier offiziell gibt. Improved security across the stack. Upgraded app discovery. Oh,
oh, oh, Leute, ich fürchte, das sieht nach mehr Snaps aus. Wenn es nach mehr Snaps aussieht,
dann uninstall ich gleich wieder. Ansonsten die ganze Welt hat sicherlich auf neues App Center
gewartet. Oh nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Das sind mehr Packages
als jetzt Snap. Cagway Business, Alter. Oh, da kein Bock drauf. Was ist an Snap so schlimm? Sagt
es die ultimative Begründung dafür? War das der Ubuntu Installer? Ah, das war der Ubuntu Installer.
Da habe ich schon gewonnen. Was ist jetzt? Willkommen to Ubuntu. Jubantu 23.10. So,
Englisch. Okay, das ist also der neue Installer. Den Snap Store gab es schon früher, aber jetzt ist
anscheinend noch mehr Snap. Geh mal weg, Alter. Ist das der neue Installer? Das sieht ein bisschen
aus wie der neue Installer. So, install. Esperanto, klar. Auf geht's. Choose your keyboard layout.
Detect. Press Y. Yes. Press Ö. No. Okay, er hat es erkannt. German no dead keys. Hey, die erste
Distribution, die tatsächlich mal das Tastatur-Layout auswählt, was ich auch immer haben will. German
no dead keys. Nicht einfach nur German, normal. Nein, ich will German no dead keys, weil beste.
Next. Use wired weird champ connection. Moment, man kann den Installer mittlerweile hotfix
updaten. Jetzt wird es aber richtig, richtig advanced. Oh ne, muss ich jetzt nochmal alle
Seiten? Naja, alles. Ist ja nicht so, als wäre das super viel gewesen. Gibt es no dead key auch
für Windows? Keine Ahnung. Ich denke schon. Eventuell habe ich es sogar eingestellt. Zeig mal
her. Nein, ich habe es nicht eingestellt. Irgendjemand, der auch früher in MMOs immer
den hier gespammt hat. So für alles. So, keine Ahnung. Kackgruppe. Ja, das ist, das ist, heute
ist das out. Das macht man heute nicht mehr. So, also choose your keyboard layout. Ne, ne, ne,
ne, ne. Nochmal. Y. Yes, wir haben ein Ö key. Ja, nein, wir sind nicht. No dead key. Als nächstes.
Weird champ connection. Ja, das ist jetzt auch neu, habe ich irgendwo gelesen. Es gibt jetzt
standardmäßig nur noch die default installation. Früher war das die full installation. Allerdings
wollen wir trotzdem third party, na gut, graphics und hardware. Mal gucken, ob die es mittlerweile
geschafft haben, weil viele Installer haben es ja mittlerweile geschafft. Mal gucken, ob es der
Ubuntu Installer mittlerweile auch geschafft hat, dass er vor MWR. Wie heißt das? Gäst? Wie
heißt das nochmal richtig? Die forever tools halt. Wie heißen die? Wie heißen die? Ich glaube,
die forever tools heißen offiziell forever tools. Ja, ja, die meine ich. Genau. Was ist jetzt
passiert? Erased disk und install Ubuntu. Jawohl. Ja, ja, ja, ja, mach mal. Wir sind in Berlin,
Germany. So ganz passt der Kram nicht wirklich in die Textboxen, aber ich will mich ja mal nicht
beschweren und alles gut. Choose your name. Keck. Your computer's name. Keck we nan. Besser.
Passwort. Pass auf Passwort. Require my password to log in. Use active. Nein. Hey,
und er nervt immer noch nicht rum. Das ist ein weakes Passwort. Bin ich ja echt froh drum. Dark.
Dark blue. Dark. Dark blue. Okay. Next. Ich bin begeistert, wie das sogar unter Desktop
Linux mittlerweile besser funktioniert und konsistenter ist als Dark Mode in Windows 11.
Dark Mode in Windows 11 und Windows 10 auch ist einfach komplett zerstückelt und wir Chat Chat.
Was ist? Was ist los? Seid ihr schon drin? Ja, habt ihr die Cybernuke gelaunched? Was geht mit
dem Installer? Die Animation hier. Jetzt ist aber mal gut, man. Was? Was hat der Installer für
Schmerzen? Das liegt, glaube ich, weniger am Dark Mode, sondern dass der Installer in der
Vm nicht ordentlich funktioniert. Hat es jemand auch in einer nicht Vm bisher gehabt? Ob das
System up to date nach dem Install ist? Ich glaube, macht er nicht während dem Installieren? Macht
er nicht nach dem Installieren direkt Updates oder noch während dem Installieren? Oh, Leute,
wir haben nicht nur 23.10, wir haben 23.10.1. Ich erkenne gar nicht so, jetzt wollte ich gerade
aufs Termin, gar nicht so viel Unterschied zum alten Installer. Der alte Installer war ein
bisschen, glaube ich, ein bisschen gestauchter und kompakter, aber geht auch voll klar. Restart. Ja,
restart now. Ubuntu 16.10 gab es auch mal. Yes, yes, enter. War da ausgehängt. Okay,
Bock. Mal gucken, ob Forever Tools drauf sind. Ich glaube es ja nicht. Da ist es. Meine Maus ist
weg. Ich habe keine Maus. Es sieht aber so aus, als sind Forever Tools drauf. Okay, nice. Ich
habe keine. Ah, jetzt habe ich eine Maus. Das ist bestimmt, weil wieder Wayland Shit in der Vm
nicht richtig funktioniert. Ja, Legacy Feature braucht man nicht mehr. Stimmt, das ist komplett
outdated mit Maus. Sehe ich auch so. Connect your account. Nein, nein, nein, wir connecten hier
nichts. Nein, wir improven auch nicht Ubuntu. Next. Location Service ist aus. Neues App Center. Aha,
da haben wir es. Das neue App Center. Cheese. Okay, was ist, wenn ich da nach Rider suche?
Kriegt man das dann direkt? Hey, aber es ist bestimmt ein Snap, oder? Ist es ein Snap? Ist
es von Nachteil, Rider als Snap zu installieren? Mr. Robot, danke schön für den Sub. Mir fällt
jetzt erstmal so spontan keiner ein, aber es ist in der Regel alles ein Nachteil per Snap zu
installieren. Es ist die minimale Installation, ja. Echt, woran? Ach hier, Confinement Classic.
Ja, dann sieht man, dass es ein Snap ist. So, Visual Studio Code ist wahrscheinlich auch ein
Snap. Ah, das ist so ätzend, Alter. Ganzes Snap Shit, lasst mich doch mal in Ruhe mit dem Kack.
So, Firefox und so ist bestimmt auch ein Snap. Äh, hallo? Äh, Chrome ist alles ein Snap. Okay,
Terminal ist bestimmt auch ein Snap. Ne, das wäre es jetzt, äh. Moment, was ist, was ist das? Also
ein Argument, warum Snap kacke ist, ist zum Beispiel, das ist das erste, was mir jetzt
einfällt, dass X-Formatting nicht mehr richtig funktioniert. Wenn du auf dem Server drauf bist,
installierst Firefox, willst X-Formatting machen, geht nicht mehr. Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher,
was ich, was ich mir jetzt installiere, aber wir installieren wir uns mal Terminal Parrot. Einfach
weil es geht und ich es zufällig im App Store gefunden habe. Äh, äh, wo kriege ich ein Startmenü,
sowas hier, Terminal? Ja, Gnome ist, Gnome ist immer so ein bisschen, ich, ich mag ja Gnome
überhaupt nicht. Ich mag übrigens KDE auch nicht. Ich mag keinen Linux Desktop. Das einzige, was ich
mag, ist mein eigenes i3 Setup und das war's. So, und wie Terminal? Das ist, ich glaube, es ist eines
der essentiellsten Packages, die man, also wirklich zwingend benötigt. Zwingend. Must have, ja. So,
wir gucken mal, ob es so eine Manpage dafür gibt. Oh, gibt es ein Help? Hey! Okay, wir können in
Orientation. Pass auf, jetzt steht er auf dem Kopf oder sowas. Ich dachte es mir schon. Ja gut,
es ist jetzt in Australien, da steht er auf dem Kopf, alles klar. Ja, das kenne ich auch,
Parrot Life. Es gibt ja noch ein paar solcher Sachen. Okay, must have package entdeckt. Terminal
Parrot, alles klar. So, aber jetzt, ich wollte eigentlich mal gucken, was es Neues gibt. Ach,
das ist mein Auge, man. Kann man das vielleicht mal, ja, viel angenehmer. Also, was haben wir
Neues? Upgraded App Discovery. Was ist denn da Neues, wenn man Apps discoveren will? Fast,
intuitive, user-friendly, Snap and Debian Packages. Ja gut, ich muss sagen, ich finde,
ich finde diese neue App-Ansicht gar nicht mal so übel. Kennt jemand noch diesen alten
GUI-Installer, den Debian mal hatte? Ich glaube, hieß das so? Ja, kennt das Ding noch jemand?
Das war echt letztes Jahrhundert, wenn man sich das anguckt. Passt mal auf, ich zeige euch das
mal. Vielleicht ist es auch mittlerweile. Okay, es sieht nicht mal ganz so antik aus wie früher,
aber auch relativ antik. Wobei ich das vielleicht fast angenehmer finde als den App Store. So,
mal gucken, ob uninstallen gescheit funktioniert. Okay, ja, immerhin. So,
schauen wir mal, ist das System up-to-date? Wie macht man eigentlich einen offiziellen
Update? Okay, so macht man das anscheinend. Oh, Leute, er hat geupgradet direkt beim
installieren. Das ist auch mal was. Das haben sie früher auch nicht hingekriegt. Ist das bei
Ubuntu jetzt eigentlich alles mit Flutter? Sollte es sein? Haben die was gesagt,
dass die mit Flutter machen wollen? Das ist alles garantiert weiterhin irgendwelche wildes
GTK-Mischmasch. Das hier weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht ist das App Center Alpha. Okay,
find us on shithub. Gucken wir mal. Ich glaube es ja nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Doch,
oh, guck mal da. Das neue App Center ist in Flutter. Okay, das ist ganz interessant. Das
heißt also auch, der, ach deswegen flimmert das wahrscheinlich auch in der VM so kacke. Aha. Was
aber auch im Endeffekt heißt, dass Desktop Support in Flutter, solange man unter Wayland läuft,
wahrscheinlich ganz brauchbar funktioniert. Gibt es einen Grund, warum Flutter, weil die immer mal
wieder alle paar Jahre neue Sachen benutzen müssen? Erinnert sich noch einer an diese
Geschichten, wo Ubuntu den eigenen Display Manager und so machen wollte und dann kam dann
mir raus und Mutter, Mutter hieß das Ding. Also hat niemand benutzt außer Ubuntu. Hat
das eigentlich sowas wie Produktbewertung? Nur mal so eine blöde, blöde Frage. Also
mal genau, ich klicke jetzt Chromium an. Nö, gibt's nicht. Ja, das ist natürlich doof. Games.
Ja, aber das ist so ziemlich der primitivste App Store, den ich kenne dann aber, oder? Ich meine,
das hat weder die Möglichkeiten, dass du darin kommentierst, noch kannst du Bewertungen sehen.
Das mag zwar schick sein, aber es ist trotzdem der schlechteste App Store, den ich kenne. Man
kann es ja nicht wirklich App Store nehmen, nennen, quasi App, ähm, tja, wie soll man es denn nennen?
App, App Selector. Aber als wir letztens, was haben wir ausprobiert? Ich glaube, ich glaube,
der Linux Mint, der App, dieses App Center, das hatte Bewertungen. Was ich auch ganz praktisch
finde und am besten wäre ja, ganz ehrlich, am besten wäre ja, wenn das gar nicht so sehr
distributionsspezifisch ist. Ja, wobei, man muss das schon machen. Einfach, dass man mehr Bewertungen
hat. Ja, das Code Store kann mehr. Gut, was macht eigentlich der Button hier oben? Das ist so
typische Gnome-Philosophie, da ist ein Button, man weiß aber nicht, wofür er da ist. Ah,
Expose, Exposed, Expose, View macht das. Und Multiple Desktops durchswitchen. Viel interessanter
gibt es, braucht man noch Gnome Tweaks und diesen Krempel, dass das ordentlich funktioniert? Nee,
gell? Braucht man, braucht man jetzt mittlerweile nicht. Wie geht man hier in die Settings rein?
Geht nicht. Hier? Okay, Overlay Description ist outdated. Appearance. Gibt es wobbly Windows?
So, jetzt wollen wir erstmal irgendwas ordentliches. Okay, so. Nicht, dass es notwendig wäre. Was ist
das? Wie ein Pixel-Wikinger. Ach, das ist der Minotaurus, weil, weil es, weil die heißt,
das aktuelle Ubuntu heißt doch irgendwas mit Minotaurus oder eher Mantic Minotaur,
Minotaur, wie auch immer man das ausspricht. Minotaur. Kann das nicht aussprechen. Gibt es
wobbly Windows? Nein, gibt es wahrscheinlich nicht, weil wobbly Windows ist einfach too,
too advanced für Ubuntu. So, das ist auch neu, dass es irgendeinen Tiling-Helper gibt,
habe ich auch irgendwo gelesen. Desktop-Icons, okay. Allerwichtigstes über. Okay, so schon mal
nicht. Okay, so. Wie kriegt man das? Okay, mal glauben, ich will ein Terminal-Desktop-Icon haben,
so. Wie kriegt man ein Desktop-Icon? Hat Gnome Desktop-Icons? Na, ich würde mal vermuten,
wenn es Settings für Desktop-Icons gibt. Da unten ist schon mal ein Icon, okay. Warum auch immer
es standardmäßig Bottom-Right ist, anstatt Top-Left. Man weiß es nicht, Top-Left guckt
man anscheinend zu genau hin. Okay, ich habe legit keine Ahnung, wie man Desktop-Icons dahin
bekommt. Ich dachte ja, man kann vielleicht das irgendwie hier track und droppen, aber kann man
nicht. Vielleicht kann man es zu Dash pinnen und dann, und dann droppen. Okay, da müssen wir mal
Google fragen. Ubuntu, how to apps Desktop? How do I put apps on my Jubantu? You navigate to user
share applications and... Was? Das kann jetzt nicht in den Ernst sein, oder? Das glaube ich
nicht. Okay, wir machen mal den File-Manager auf, ob man da irgendwas sieht. Wir haben einen
Home-Folder, wir haben keinen Desktop-Folder. Kann ich es vielleicht so machen? Nee. If you click
on Desktop and begin to track it, a new bookmark will appear in the red. Was? Okay, how to add
application shortcuts. Oh, irgendeine indische Seite. Okay, jetzt lassen wir uns das beibringen.
Als erstes, Moment, you block origin. Muss mal kurz in den Browser rein. Firefox. Warum ist im
Desktop dir die Home-Verknüpfung nicht angezeigt? Äh, da ist es doch. Okay, adding Desktop-Shortcuts
in Ubuntu. Okay, also, personally I prefer... Ja, laber nicht rum, sag mir, wie es geht.
Ah. Locate a Desktop-File. Ist das wirklich, ihr in Ernst, oder was? Jetzt, jetzt, Chat,
ich habe gedacht, ihr verarscht mich. Go to user share applications. Ein Ernstes, ja? User share,
ja? Nee, äh, Moment, wie navigiert man hier überhaupt? Äh, ähm, Moment. Nein, nein, nein,
wir machen das wie die letzten Kack-Moves. Wir machen das nicht im Terminal. Nicht im Terminal,
Leute. Ctrl-L. Im Terminal weiß jeder, wie das geht. Das muss über den GUI-Explorer hier
gemacht werden. Ah, ah, Ctrl-L. Warum auch nicht Ctrl-L? User share applications. Das ist ja,
das ist ja 2001, Alter. Selbst da ging das schon besser. Übrigens, früher unter Ubuntu ging das,
ne? Das ist jetzt nur... Ein weiterer Punkt, warum ich Gnome nicht wirklich mag. Also,
ich mag auch KDE nicht, kann ich gleich dazu sagen. Ich mag eigentlich nichts auf dem Linux-Desktop,
außer meinen selbst eingerichteten i3. Und den mag ich auch nur, weil er einfach nichts macht,
weil er so gut wie es geht im Hintergrund bleibt. Okay, from here you go to user share,
you will see icons of several Ubuntu-Applications. Also, ich sehe hier ehrlich gesagt keine icons of
several Ubuntu-Applications, sondern ich sehe hier einfach nur Vim-Desktop zum Beispiel. Ah,
da ist er. Ne, ist er nicht. Und jetzt copy the desktop file to the desktop. Aber jetzt verschiebe
ich's. Okay, firefox. Copy. Paste. Hey, hey, oi, es hat funktioniert. Guck mal da. Aber warum sieht
das jetzt so verkrüppelt aus? So ein bisschen kaputt sieht's schon aus, oder? Properties.
Select custom icons. Ja, wo kämen wir da auch hin, wenn ich hier irgendwie direkt bei custom icons
jetzt eine Icon-Selection hätte oder sowas? Warum sieht das so kacke aus? Oh. Ah, invalid
permissions. Ey, das ist so, also nicht, dass es mich stört. Ich würd's nochmal erwähnen. Aber
das ist wirklich schon selten bescheuert gemacht, Alter. Das ist schon selten bescheuert. Kann man
vielleicht, ich mein, das ist ja sogar unter Windows besser. Und das heißt schon was. Du
musst auf plus other locations gehen. Okay, Chat, ich lass mir das GUI-Zeug jetzt von euch erklären.
Other locations. Ubuntu. Und jetzt? User. Share. Applications. Ja, da war ich doch eben schon.
So, Firefox. Ne, geht nicht. Permissions. Read. Write. Execute gibt's nicht. Execute. Was? Right-click,
then enable launching. Allow launching. Boah, ist das hängen geblieben, Mann. Ist das hängen
geblieben. Gut, das ist ja ein weiterer Grund dafür, warum ich keinerlei Linux-Desktops mag,
außer mein i3. Der hat sowas gar nicht. Der hat gar keine Desktops. Mein i3 hat einfach nur,
ja doch, doch mehrere Desktops schon, aber keine Icons oder sowas, dass ich White Paper Happy
Backgrounds in Full HD 4K Resolution hier mir angucken kann. Das ist mein i3, den ihr grad
siehst. So, im Prinzip hat der i3 nix, außer nen Browser auf dem ersten Desktop, nen Terminal auf
dem zweiten Desktop und ja, eventuell nen Editor und ne IDE auf dem dritten und vierten. Fertig,
mehr gibt's nicht. Und wenn ich was starten will, mach ich's darüber. Zack, zack, jetzt hier,
zack, Rider, bam, starten, gut. Toolbox nochmal starten, mal gucken, ob's da irgendwas zu upgraden
gibt. Easy. Deswegen ist i3, oh guck mal, es gibt neue Updates. Deswegen ist i3 auch das Einfachste,
das Einzige. Was ist Writersite? Die haben ja mittlerweile auch echt alles. Was ist Writersite?
JetBrains Writersite. Eine Dokumentations-IDE. Early Access. Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt übertreiben
sie's. Okay, wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Jubantu. Okay, also, ich habe gelernt, Desktop-Icons
anlegen ist unter Gnome bzw. Ubuntu schonmal nicht, nicht so, nicht so gedacht, ja. Schreibt
doch eh keiner Dokus. Ja, ist ja auch, ist ja auch Zeitverschwendung, Dokus zu schreiben. Genauso
wie Tests oder Kommentare. Es muss einfach fehlerfrei sein, first try funktionieren und
halt immer gehen. Dann brauchst du den Rest auch nicht. Dass die Leute heutzutage sich
immer noch erlauben können, irgendwelche Fehler zu programmieren. Ich finde, wir sollten
Errorless Programming einführen. Failureless Programming. Und dann immer schön agil mit
Mikrosprints diagonal skalieren. Und dann kann eigentlich nix passieren. Was kann man
hier sonst noch Neues machen? Das Dock-Hiden. Leute, ich weiß gar nicht, was das Dock ist.
Könnt ihr mir erklären, was das Dock ist? Also außer, außer, dass die Icons näher ran rücken.
Ah, wenn man minimiert vielleicht. Nee. Ach, das hier. Ähm, was hat das für? Okay,
okay. Warum sorgt das für andere Orientierung in die, für die Icons? Ich, ich finde es ja
deutlich angenehmer, dass die Icons dort an der Seite sind, aber so ist die Uhrzeit auch
gar nicht zentriert, oder? Das ist das kleinste Problem, was stammt. Ich glaube, ich darf das
die Icons nicht sehen. Deswegen sind die Icons auch bottom right, damit keinem auffällt,
dass das top left nicht funktioniert. Zieh mal das Fenster nach links mit Dock an. Ja,
dann ist es halt oben drüber. Unknown primary display. Primary display. All displays. Oh yeah.
Apps. What? Oh yeah. So, ansonsten lohnt sich das hier, glaube ich, nicht großartig noch was zu
gucken, was das angeht. Oh, sehr minimalistisch. Also wie gesagt, da ist mir Linux Mint tatsächlich
um Längen lieber, wenn es irgendwie so eine GUI heavy Distribution sein muss. Was ich,
was ich echt ganz interessant finde, ist, dass der Installer jetzt anscheinend in Flutter ist.
Ey, den gibt's leider nicht. 22 Fiat Champ Issues. Ja, ich weiß. Ist Schach vorinstalliert? Chess?
Nein. Ich hab's auch auf Englisch. Ist nicht, nicht vorinstalliert. Wir können mal gucken,
was vorinstalliert ist. Okay, es ist wirklich sehr minimal, oder? Das ist alles. Hier, das ist alles.
Es gibt Software und Updates und Software Updater. Ah, das sind die Settings. Okay,
es ist minimal. System Monitor haben wir noch, so eine Task Manager. Der ist tatsächlich ganz
praktisch. Der, der konnte auch noch ein paar sinnvolle Sachen. Ja, der ist gar nicht so schlecht,
wenn man, wenn man da, wenn man ein UI dafür haben will und mit H-Top, B-Top und den 1000 Top
Varianten nicht zurechtkommt. So, jetzt lasst uns doch mal das Dokument angucken. Was,
was denn jetzt eigentlich wirklich Neues, Neues dabei? Okay, machen wir mal What's New. Ach ne,
ich hab das ja vorhin hier aufgemacht. Also, App Discovery Support für Raspberry Pi 5. Ja,
gut, da habe ich noch keinen. Ich bestelle mir einen vor, sobald es den gibt. Ich glaube,
ich glaube, den gibt es jetzt diese Woche, oder? Ich glaube, ab dieser Woche kann man
den vorbestellen. Naja, nächste Woche. Nächste Woche Montag. Kann man den bestellen. Ich werde
mir direkt einen bestellen. Ich brauche keinen, aber irgendwie will ich ja einen haben. Ich habe
mir auch zwei Raspberry Pi Zero Ws bestellt. Äh, Zero W2 war das, gell? Ja, ja. Zero W2 damals,
als sie neu waren und nichts damit gemacht bisher. Aber, aber Hauptsache, Hauptsache haben.
Deeper Integration for Familiar Administration Tools. Networking Experience. Desktop now uses
NetPlan. Okay, meinetwegen. Könnten die nicht NetPlan einfach rausschmeißen? NetPlan war eines
der Hauptgründe, warum ich Ubuntu nicht mehr auf meinen Servern installiere. Okay,
Netzwerksettings. Ich meine, für, für, im Prinzip ist es ja für die, für den reinen User echt gar
kein Ding. Ob man jetzt, ob das, ist das Absicht? Dass das eigentlich kein Popup ist, was man schieben
kann? Das fühlt sich weird an. Oder ist das ein Bug? Flutter, Flutter Champ. Ja, aber ich glaube nicht,
dass die, die Gnome User Settings Flutter ist. Das wäre ein bisschen zu abgedreht. Ja, genau.
Das glaube ich auch nicht, dass das Flutter ist. Das ist irgendwelches GTK Gedöns. Okay,
jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, ob das die Möglichkeit hat, z.B. Port Security Sachen zu
setzen. Anscheinend, ah doch, hat es, hat es. Okay, gut, gut, gut, gut. Das ist gut. Ja, das ist gut.
Braucht man da heimlich? Man braucht das in Business Enterprise Umgebungen und wenn das nicht über das
GUI geht, wäre, wäre doof. Aber das ist nice, dass man Port Security Sachen darüber setzen kann. So, das,
das fühlt sich übelst weird an. Hier zu tracken und dann bewegt sich das ganze Fenster. Die Gnome Leute
haben teilweise schon ein bisschen merkwürdige Ansichten, was irgendwie intuitiv ist. Ja, was?
Wegen dir habe ich fast lachen müssen, als meine Wirtschaftslehrerin unironisch von dem diagonalen
skalieren geredet hat. Ich dachte davor, dass das Insider, ist es auch nur, dass sie damit was
anderes meint als ich. Die meint damit halt wirklich diagonal skalieren und ich meine damit
eine Kombination aus Cloud-Infrastruktur, vertikal und horizontal gleichzeitig skalieren, was keinen
Sinn ergibt. Wie weit ist eigentlich das Rust-Desktop-Environment von Pop! OS? Moment, die, die wollen
ein, ein Desktop-Environment in Rust bauen. Warum denn? Okay, was für, was für eine Frage. Warum? Weil
blazingly fast fritten in Rust, was denn sonst? Ja genau, das ist auch so ein Ding, genau. Die Gnome-Leute
finden auch, dass das, das ist überflüssig. Haben die hier eigentlich auch in die JetBrains Toolbox?
Okay, Leute, habt ihr, sagt mir mal eine Anwendung, die definitiv, ja doch, das hier hat, hat, wenn man
die minimiert, wenn man die minimiert, hat das auf jeden Fall, das ist bestimmt auch ein Snap, oder?
Ja, das ist auf, das hat auf jeden Fall ein Desktop, Desktop-Icon. Okay, nochmal schauen, ob es ein Desktop-Icon
gibt. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Tools, Options. Erstmal Dark Theme. Apply. Okay, gut. So, und wo stellt man das jetzt
mit dem Minimieren ein? Application. Minimized. Okay. Apply. Es geht, es geht bestimmt nicht. Nö. Es gibt keine, es gibt
keine Tray-Icons. Tray-Icons sind outdated, overrated. Braucht man nicht. Hat, hat das Gnome-Projekt
entschieden, niemand benutzt Tray-Icons. Außer, außer selbst, selbst Tray-Icons, das ist okay, aber
zusätzliche Tray-Icons gibt es einfach nicht. Oh, Moment, habe ich jetzt Mist erzählt? Da stand Tray-Icon
Enable. Ich dachte, das ist standardmäßig. Da, vielleicht, vielleicht ist es auch nicht so. Options. Ach, da.
Does not work in all Desktop-Environments. Auch interessant, dass es keine Haken, keine Hicksen gibt,
sondern einfach nur, oh. Soll das so sein? Ich glaube nicht, oder? Oh, Leute, wir haben Tray-Icons. Das
funktioniert ja tatsächlich. Damit hätte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet. Das ist irgendeine, das ist
garantiert irgendeine Gnome-Extension, die die dabei haben. Das Jahr des Linux-Desktops ist hier, Leute.
Tray-Icons am Start. Okay, immerhin, immerhin kann man das jetzt verwenden. Das ist ja, ist doch schon
mal was. So, was haben wir denn sonst noch Schönes Neues? Ah, ich muss hier gucken, sonst blendet es sonst so sehr.
Popular Plugins for Refreshed Docker. What? Okay, Docker will, Docker Developers will replace that
Jubantu. 23.10 includes latest and alongside. Docker Build X. Ja, gut, Docker Compose ist auch dabei. Ist
Docker Compose nicht, Moment, was ist Docker Compose V2? Ich dachte eigentlich, dass Docker Compose
mittlerweile Bestandteil von Docker Compose ist. Sorry, dass Docker Compose mittlerweile Bestandteil
von Docker ist. Oder nicht? Ich dachte eigentlich, dass Docker Compose mittlerweile included ist in
Docker. Wie, das war es jetzt? Das ist aber nicht so viel. Okay, also was gibt es noch? Installation
Changes. Das haben wir schon gesehen. Minimal by Default, ja. App Center. Hier haben wir ja App. Was ist das für ein Ding? Ach, das Ding. Das Ding, wo man
beispielsweise NVIDIA Treiber und so installiert. Ja, gut, da habe ich in der VM natürlich nichts. Sicher, dass
es separat ist? Echt? Ich, okay, vielleicht, Moment, Moment. Guckt mal, ich habe doch hier, oh, tatsächlich,
es ist immer noch. Ich dachte eigentlich, dass es mittlerweile integriert ist. Habe ich gar nicht
mehr installiert. Ich dachte, mittlerweile ist Docker Compose mit dabei. Das sieht nach Flutter
aus, meinst du? Du meinst, dass das Firmware-Update-Ding, keine Ahnung, ob das Flutter ist.
Man erkennt, also, ja doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, guck mal, guck mal. Seht ihr das? Na, wobei, das sieht
ein bisschen anders aus hier oben. Das, wahrscheinlich ist es, wahrscheinlich ist es doch Flutter. Kann,
kann, kann aber auch was Normales sein. Man, dafür erkenne ich jetzt echt nicht genug. So, was haben wir
sonst noch hier? Workspace Indicator. Uh, äh, was? GTK 3 vs. GTK 4 juckt mich überhaupt nicht. Ich benutze
trotzdem kein Knochen. Okay, Elegantly animates. Das probieren wir jetzt. Wie elegantly das das
macht, so da. Massive elegant. Hyper elegantly. Ich finde, das macht optisch doch schon ganz
guten Eindruck. Settings gibt es hier natürlich keine, bei Gnome gibt es generell immer relativ
wenig Settings. Es ist so blöd, dass Compits irgendwie dead ist, beziehungsweise vom Ansatz
her sich nicht so gut für die Zukunft geeignet hat. Compits war einfach so nice mit dem, mit dem
Würfel hier und, und Wobbly Windows und sowas. Gibt es, gibt es für Ubuntu, gibt es Wobbly? Gibt
es die Möglichkeit, Wobbly Windows zu machen? How to enable Wobbly Windows Effect. Ja, jawoll,
jawoll, jawoll. Wo, wo, wo? Ach so, okay, die Hälfte ist schon wieder kaputt. Leider, leider geht
das nicht mehr. So, was haben wir sonst noch hier? Keyboard Backlight. Ja gut, das sehe ich jetzt
nicht. File Manager Changes. Der File Manager, was ist denn das jetzt für einer? Ist es nicht mehr?
Der Standart, wie war das, hieß das Ding mal Gnome, Nautilus oder so? Nein, das heißt einfach
Files. War das nicht mal früher Nautilus? Ach, ist doch Nautilus, stand doch sogar noch da. Ja,
das fühlt sich, Leute, ohne Mist, das fühlt sich irgendwie falsch an, wenn ich hier, das Track
das mit, das fühlt sich einfach weird an. Tweaks, aber da gibt es nichts viel spannendes. Fedora,
ey, wird ja noch schlimmer. Ich würde beides nicht verwenden auf dem Desktop. Die sieht,
die sieht nicht aus wie Chico, aber ist auch eine dreifarbige. Kollege von Chico. Enhanced
Window Tiling. Okay, wie funktioniert das jetzt? Okay, gibt es das auch, das probieren wir jetzt
gleich mal aus. Gibt es da auch die Möglichkeit, das mit Tastatur Shortcuts zu machen? Aha,
okay. Nix, was ich benutzen werde. Windows-File-Taste, aber da kann man nur links,
rechts. Okay, das ist ein bisschen doof. Es gibt so halbe Tastatur-Unterstützung,
aber man kann es nicht unten links hin teilen. Naja, okay, da habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt
nicht drauf gewartet. Ja, und der Windows funktioniert sowas ja prinzipiell schon
seit Jahren nicht. Deswegen mag ich i3. In i3 habe ich zwar keine Shortcuts, doch,
habe ich Shortcuts, aber verwende ich keine Shortcuts. In i3 mache ich so, ah, guck mal,
ich brauche hier einen Terminal, zack, zack, und einen Terminal, oder so. Oder wenn ich noch einen
Terminal brauche, dann so. So, fertig. Also da passiert eigentlich überhaupt nichts und dann
kann man es ja immer noch ein bisschen verschieben mit der Maus. Ich finde, das geht zwar auch mit
Shortcuts, aber ich verschiebe es dann immer ganz gern mit der Maus, weil da kann man es einfach
besser einstellen. So, fertig. So mache ich das unter i3. So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Firefox Snap Changes. Ne, Snap. Okay, neuer Linux-Kernel. Oh, New Advanced Install Options,
ZFS File System und Highly Experimental TPM. Wollen wir mal Experimental Install mit ZFS
machen? Weil so viel gibt es da sonst nicht auszuprobieren. Ich finde den übrigens sehr,
sehr Brock, den Typ hier, weil der hat seine ganzen Cats im Hintergrund. Also wenn man eins
von Windows 11 gelernt hat, dass Sachen, die unter Windows 10 problemlos funktioniert haben,
nicht zwangsläufig unter Windows 11 auch problemlos funktionieren müssen. Oder Sachen,
die noch unter Windows 95 funktioniert haben, auch nicht funktionieren müssen unter Windows 11 oder
Windows 10. Zum Beispiel, falls ihr es noch nicht wusstet, so was geht nicht. Also man kann nichts
mehr auf die Taskleiste tracken. Ich glaube man kann mittlerweile auch nichts runtertracken. Aber
manche Sachen, manche Sachen kann man tracken. Ja, zum Beispiel eine Verknüpfung auf dem Programm.
Ganz, ganz weird, weird champ. Okay, dann würde ich sagen, wir installieren doch tatsächlich
nochmal neu mit der ZFS Option. Wollen wir groß ausprobieren? Gibt ja nichts auszuprobieren.
Ja, set. Jubantu, please booten von CD. Okay, es hat mega schnell gebootet. Also das muss man ja
sagen. Es hat übelst hyper schnell gebootet gerade. Habt ihr das gesehen? Das ist nicht schlecht. Aber
ich würde gerne... Warum geht VMware gerade nicht mehr in das... Sollte VMware nicht eigentlich in
dieses VMware booted Ding gehen? Warum macht es das nicht mehr? Ist das so placingly fast
Jubantu, dass es einfach nicht... Da ist es doch! Nee, ist es nicht. Hä? Ja, ISO is connected.
Interessant. Das ist tatsächlich... Hätte ich das... Wusste ich jetzt... Das ist jetzt... Ich weiß
gar nicht, was sie da gemacht haben. So, es gab doch irgendwie die Möglichkeit zu sagen,
on next boot, geh ins BIOS. Wenn ich jetzt noch wüsste, wo das ist. Exclusive fullscreen. Nee,
kann nicht mehr aktiv sein. Nein, nein, das Bootmenü taucht da tatsächlich nicht mehr auf.
Man konnte doch hier in VMware irgendwo... Okay, ich muss mal kurz gucken.
VMware next boot BIOS. VM power, power on to BIOS. Es? Es gibt keine Option. VMware
debated mich. Das gibt es überhaupt nicht. Ach, tatsächlich. Okay, power off. Ich habe
nichts gesagt. Okay. So, CD ist connected und jetzt boot to removable CD-ROM drive. Ach so,
das ist ja fast wie 1995 hier. Try or install Jubantu. Jetzt machen wir das mal mit ZFS. Das
finde ich interessant, was die da... Ob das funktioniert. Time to install Templo S. Ja,
Templo S hat bestimmt den noch viel geileren Tiling Window Manager. Hat Templo S überhaupt
sowas wie Fenster oder irgendwie so ein Konzept davon? Weil man weiß nicht, ob da Gott zugestimmt
hat. Weil wenn da Gott nicht zugestimmt hat, dann konnte er das ja nicht einbauen. Der hat
einen Window Manager, gut. Aber nur mit 16 Bit und auch nur 256 Farben und sowas, weil mehr ist
ja nicht erlaubt. Wo macht man das überhaupt mit dem... Ihr müsst jetzt mal mit mir Ausschau halten,
wo man das findet, dass der ZFS installieren soll. Kann es sein, dass der Installer nicht geht? Und
meine Maus geht auch nicht. Oh, da ist er. Da ist er. Meine Maus geht wieder nicht. Next. Die
Maus ist broken. Jetzt müssen wir... Getreiber. Quatsch. Jetzt müssen wir blind klicken. Moment,
jetzt ist... Hä? Jetzt ist die Maus da. Use weird connect... Jetzt muss ich wieder updaten und dann
nochmal starten. Aber jetzt bleibt meine Maus auch da. Das muss an Wayland im Zusammenhang mit
Forever liegen. Das funktioniert eh nicht richtig. Next. Normal detecten. Yes. No. Next. Okay,
wo wählt man das aus? Ubuntu. ZFS. Okay, wie geht das? How to. ZFS. Vielleicht kommt das ja
gleich noch. Okay, die Vorinstallation. Ja, ja, mach hier mal. Advanced Features. Experimental
Erase disk and use ZFS. Zack. Next. Okay. Dinger. ZFS-Dinger. Install. Europe Berlin.
Keck W. Nein, das ist Keck W. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Next. Weak Passwort. Das ist
best practice Passwort. Das Passwort haben so viele Leute auf der Welt, das kann nicht schlecht
sein. Das ist etabliert. Die Animation hier unten ist auch nicht so richtig flüssig. Oh,
das ist ein bisschen wie im Krankenhaus. Also der Installer hat auf jeden Fall in der VM echt
Probleme mit dem Refreshen vom Screen bzw. vom Repaint on der App. Das schiebe ich jetzt
tatsächlich mal ein bisschen auf Flutter, weil GTK Anwendungen haben das nicht passiert. Was war
eigentlich die Idee von Canonical, da jetzt den Flutter Installer hinzustellen? Weil nicht,
dass ich schlecht finde. Der originale, der alte Installer, das war jetzt nicht so,
dass ich sagen würde, oh geil, der hat es getan. Wahrscheinlich einfach, weil es neu ist,
oder? Dass die dann sagen können auf irgendwelche Konferenz Talks, rewritten
the Jubantu Installer in Flutter und dann machen sie irgendwie eineinhalb Stunden Konferenz Talk
drüber. Was sind die Unterschiede zwischen ZFS und BTFS? Ich kann ja aus dem Kopf nicht alle
Sachen sagen. Jubantu. Ja, man muss das wie die coolen Leute aussprechen. Also ZFS ist auf jeden
Fall das verbreitetere und das bewertere. Wie bei BTFS beispielsweise RAID 5, also quasi ZFS RAID
1 ist es glaube ich. ZFS RAID plus 1 oder so ist glaube ich RAID 5. Ob das überhaupt in BTFS schon
supported ist, weiß ich nicht. Auch so Sachen wie ZFS Send, ZFS Receive ist glaube ich nicht.
Full Disk Encryption in ZFS ist glaube ich in BTFS auch nicht. Generell ist ZFS wahrscheinlich
die bessere Wahl, wenn man wirklich die ganzen Features braucht. Dafür ist ZFS recht ressourcen
hungrig, wenn man es beispielsweise NAS für viele User anbieten will und vor allem sehr RAM
hungrig. Man sollte sich da aber nicht davon abschrecken lassen, so pauschal. Man braucht
diese Sachen mit die im Internet erzählt wird. Ein Gigabyte RAM oder irgendwie was weiß ich,
was jetzt mittlerweile empfohlen ist für jedes Terabyte Storage und so. Man muss es nicht
übertreiben. Das ist für irgendwelche Enterprise File Storages dann ja vielleicht, aber für daheim
ist es egal. ZFS hat aber auch noch ein paar Falschrecke. Zum Beispiel, dass du das File
System nicht komplett füllen darfst und solche Sachen. Zumindest gab es mal das Problem, wenn
du ZFS komplettes File System 100% gefüllt hast, dann konntest du die Datei nicht mehr löschen,
weil er keine neue Datei erstellen konnte. Fragt mich nicht, was das Problem war. Ich weiß nicht.
Man konnte sich zumindest ein File System kaputt machen durch 100% füllen. Das hat dann irgendwie
einen speziellen Trick erfordert, dass es wieder geht. Okay, Restart. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
wie das ZFS mäßig funktioniert. Meine Frage, wie deployt ihr eigentlich Hilfsmaschinen? Hat mir
eine VM zurechtgemacht? Kopiert ihr immer, wenn ich einen neuen Server brauche? Das kommt ein
bisschen darauf an, ob du immer neu installieren willst und dann konfigurieren willst oder ob du
irgendein Base Image verwenden kannst. Am einfachsten ist wahrscheinlich wirklich, wenn du
viele solcher aufbaust. Du machst dir irgendeinen Ansible Playbook, installierst. In der Cloud ist es
noch einfacher. Da haust du das dann einfach in dein Cloud Init rein und lässt es automatisch
laufen. Dann macht ihr einen Ansible Playbook und gut ist. Dann installierst du das und dann ist es
da und dann lässt du dein Playbook laufen und da ist es konfiguriert. Enter. Was ist bei Ubuntu neu?
Da, guck. Haben wir uns gerade angeguckt. Ne, ich finde das Video nicht mehr. Es gibt jetzt noch
mehr Snap Packages, was ich auch nicht so geil finde und es gibt mehr einen komischen App Store,
der keine Bewertung hat. Mauszeiger da im Login nicht angezeigt wird und keine Desktop-Icons
gescheit. Snap. Es ist Ubuntu. Natürlich ist es Snap. Was sonst? Guck mal, Mauszeiger. Ah ja, da ist er wieder.
Okay, sie haben mittlerweile Forever Tools. Ich bin begeistert. Klar, du kannst also selbst, wenn es für
irgendwas kein Ansible Modul geben sollte, was du machen willst, kannst du immer noch quasi einen
Exec machen und Sachen ausführen, wie du es selbst willst. Also kannst du es selbst reinschreiben.
Nein, wir senden keine Data. Next. Und das ist jetzt auf ZFS-Basis. Ah, guck mal hier. B-Pool, R-Pool.
Okay, das GUI sollte das vielleicht hiden besser. Terminal. So Leute, jetzt hier. Achtung, meine ZFS-Skills
ist ewig her, wo ich ZFS oder Z-Pool liste. Ey, okay. Und als erstes mal den PC-Speaker ausmachen.
Terminal bell. Wobei, Chat Trick 17. Ich zeige euch jetzt was. Ich zeige euch was. Wenn euch sowas
nervt, dass Terminals und irgendwelche anderen Sachen komische PC-Speaker-Geräusche verursachen,
macht folgendes. Mod-Probe-R PC-Speaker. So. Okay, das geht anscheinend über die,
über Puls-Audio oder sowas. Ja, da bringt der PC-Speaker natürlich nicht. Da muss das weg.
Jetzt ist es aber aus. Z-Pool-List. Was gibt's denn sonst noch? Leute, mit DF war BTFS. Ich hab
überhaupt keinen Plan mehr von ZFS. Ich hab das vor Jahren zuletzt benutzt. Ich weiß gar nichts
mehr drüber. Ich weiß auch gar nicht mehr, wie man sich überhaupt anzeigen lassen kann,
wie er das jetzt konfiguriert hat. Wie kann man sich das Rate-Level davon anzeigen lassen?
Muss man da vielleicht den Pool eingeben? B-Pool? Nee, nicht B-Pool. R-Pool? Nee. Info? Oh,
keine Ahnung. Status. Okay, da sieht man, dass das ein Pool ist mit jeweils, ja gut, was soll's
auch sonst sein? Da sind ja keine Platten da dran. Mit einer Platte. Also, ganz normal. Wie
heißt das bei ZFS? Ein V-Dev ist es, glaube ich, gell? Also, nicht das, sondern das, das was sein
V-Dev. Aber sogar Boot ist auf ZFS, okay. Encrypted ist es nicht, weil man beim Booten nichts eingeben
muss. Könnte man vielleicht nachträglich machen. Weiß ich nicht, ob man schon bestehende Volumes,
mein Arsch läuft, encrypten kann. Aber dann checkt es der Bootmanager garantiert nicht.
Scheint zu funktionieren. Ich glaube, ich würde es normalerweise nicht nutzen. So cool das ist,
dass es im Installer drin ist und das ZFS halt sehr viele Features hat. Also, wenn man halt gar
keine Ahnung davon hat, fährt man mit einem einfachen X4 oder XFS auf jeden Fall besser.
Wenn man so Sachen machen will, wie beispielsweise Snapshots vom System, vielleicht Offsite die
Snapshots irgendwo hinschicken und speichern, dann ist ZFS das Beste, was es gibt. Aber ich glaube,
die wenigsten Leute wollen das mit ihrer Kiste machen und schon gar nicht mit ihrer Test-VM.
Wir haben mal, als ich angefangen habe auf Twitch, war eines der ersten Bastel-Streams,
die wir gemacht haben. ZFS on Linux, das war damals noch Beta. Ubuntu mit selbst
einkompiliertem ZFS on Linux, Beta-Encryption-Support und das per Script über SSH beim
Booten anlocken lassen. Das war echt advanceder Shit für die damalige Zeit. Hat auch funktioniert,
kriege ich aber nicht mehr zusammen jetzt. Für Desktop eh nicht, sondern nicht relevant. Okay,
interessant. Also, zumindest der Installer läuft durch und es gibt keine großartigen Probleme
auf den ersten Blick. Außer das hier im, ja, das ist natürlich doof, dass es da angezeigt wird
überhaupt. Ich habe noch nicht ganz klar mit. Ich glaube, das war's. Mehr gibt es nicht auszuprobieren.
Auf Server-Seite könnten wir jetzt gucken, ob sich irgendwas an NetPlan oder so getan hat,
aber NetPlan ist ja offensichtlich immer noch da, also hat sich da nichts dran getan. Das ist immer
noch nervig. Ich glaube, das ist alles. Mehr gibt es nicht. Wir haben uns alles angeguckt. Easy. Das
ist nice. Dann kann ich jetzt nämlich das ganze Ding wieder löschen und ein bisschen Platz auf
meiner Platte freigeben. Jubantu ist deletet. Ubuntu weg. So. Zack. Empty. Zack. Und jetzt gehen
wir nochmal hier hin und sagen Downloads. Was habe ich denn hier? Das kommt weg. Das kommt weg. Das
kommt weg. Ich habe doch bestimmt noch jede Menge. Windows 11, Proxmox. Ein bisschen Platz freigeben
auf meiner Festplatte. Das ist so eine Katastrophe, das Windows-UI. ZFS wäre also was selbst. Wenn du
es brauchst, ja. Was ist eigentlich das Compose für Podman? Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich würde
vermuten, dass Docker-Compose auch für Podman einfach funktioniert, aber ich weiß es nicht.
Habe ich noch nie ein Kombi... Oh, es gibt sogar Podman-Compose. Es hat sogar eingebaut. Guck,
noch besser. Ich mache trotzdem einen Bogen um Podman. Weiß nicht, das hat mir zu sehr Retard
draufstehen. Denkst du, mit einem MacBook hat man außer der Umgewöhnung andere Probleme, um mit
AWS zu arbeiten? Hä? Moment, den Satz verstehe ich nicht. Denkst du, mit einem MacBook hat man
außer der Umgewöhnung... Achso! Nee, hast du gar nicht. AWS juckt doch mal null, was du da hast.
Das ist perfectly fine für AWS-Administrationen und Cloud-Infrastruktursachen-Anlegen. Also auf
jeden Fall besser als Windows. Unter Windows hast du halt Probleme, dass du die ganzen Tools
nicht gescheit zum Laufen bekommst. Oder wenn, dann halt eklig, weil es ist immer noch Windows
drumherum. Mac ist eigentlich eine richtig gute Mischung aus, wenn man drauf steht,
also aus ganz brauchbarer Oberfläche plus halt alle möglichen Terminal-Tools, die man so braucht.
Und auch in aktueller Variante zum Nachinstallieren. Nö, da würde ich keine Probleme jetzt erwarten
mit Mac und AWS. Also weder mit AWS, noch mit Google, noch mit Azure, noch mit Hetzner oder
DigitalOcean. Das würde einfach funktionieren. Ach Chat, ich bin heute übrigens neuer Rekord.
Ich bin heute 54,25 Kilometer Fahrrad gefahren. Und heute Morgen war ich 7,5 Kilometer laufen. Das
ging richtig, heute war richtig, ging es richtig zur Sache. Aber 54 Kilometer, da hat mir schon die
Beine ein bisschen, da hatte ich schon keinen Bock mehr dann, die letzten paar Kilometer. Ja,
montags arbeitslos, so sieht es aus. Ich gehe am Montags immer nicht arbeiten, deswegen ist das
ein wunderbarer Tag dafür. Und heute war auch wirklich super Wetter nochmal. Da müsste ich ja
schwimmen und da habe ich gar keinen Bock drauf. Früher bin ich richtig gerne schwimmen gegangen.
Konnte auch Kilometer teilweise lang schwimmen. Das meine ich wirklich so. Aber irgendwie habe
ich gerade überhaupt keinen Bock drauf. Mir reicht das, wenn ich ein bisschen fitter werde
wieder und dann ist gut. Ich meine, ich mache das jetzt seit, so richtig viel Bewegen mache
ich jetzt seit 2 Monaten oder so. Aber ich muss sagen, es geht schon deutlich besser mit dem
Fahrradfahren als die ersten Runden. Die ersten Runde haben wir übelst der Oberschenkel gebrannt,
bei jedem mal ein bisschen in die Pedale treten. Jetzt geht es, also aktuell nicht. Das ist halt
so ein Ding, wenn ich mit irgendwas erstmal anfange, weil ich selbst Bock drauf habe,
dann mache ich es auch regelmäßig. Die letzten 15 Jahre hatte ich einfach keinen Bock auf großartig
Sport machen. Wie lange fährt man für 50 Kilometer? Ja, ziemlich genau eineinhalb Stunden
bin ich gefahren. Also wenn du richtig gut dabei bist, fährst du das bestimmt auch in kürzer,
weil Leute, die gut dabei sind, die fahren halt schon so, ja, weiß nicht, 28, 29, 30 kmh. Ja,
das Video wollte ich noch gucken. Ich habe kein E-Bike mehr. Ja, also es drückt schon ganz schön
im Oberschenkel so teilweise. Nee, nee, kein Holland ran. Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Fahrrad,
da kriegst du einen Link zu meinem Gefährt. Was drückt da? Naja, es drückt im Nachhinein,
dass man selbst den ganzen Tag drauf gedrückt hat. Also aufs Pedal und das merkst du jetzt
immer noch. Also im Oberschenkel drückt es halt. Ja, ja, mein Fahrrad. Da ist es,
guckt. So sieht es aus. So scale Kriege. Keck we business. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Das habe
ich mir überlegt, das mache ich, wenn ich mal mein Fahrrad mal ordentlich einstellen lasse.
Mache ich mir so einen Termin, da lasse ich auch gleich mir dort Schuhe verkaufen und Pedale
richtig einstellen. Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich habe ein bisschen rumgeguckt überall und das war
lieferbar. Das habe ich schon öfters mal gelesen und ich wusste auch mal, was es ist, aber jetzt
weiß ich nicht. Was ist das denn? Nee, habe ich nicht. Vorne Rad, groß, hinten klein. Nicht
umgedreht. Radlabor in Frankfurt. Okay, zeig mal, wo ist das denn? Radlabor Frankfurt. Abs
Frankfurt Westbahnhof. Das ist ein guter Hinweis, Pock. Ich Hauptbahnhof West Westbahnhof Hauptbahnhof
ist hier unten irgendwo da. Ja, gute Sache. Gute Sache. Werde ich mir, werde ich mir mal merken.
Hast du deine Garmin Aufzeichnung in Grafana? Nee, nee, aber das ist eine gute Idee. Das muss
ich mir. Geht das denn? Kriegt man den Kram irgendwie raus? Moment, das funktioniert.
Aber man muss mit dem Garmin Connect SDK das irgendwie abfragen. Aber das ist cool,
dass das funktioniert. War ja klar, dass es da schon irgendwas Fertiges gibt.
Nix kostet Grafana, außer Grafana Cloud. Okay, Leute, schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid. Ich
glaube, ich gehe jetzt pennen. Also in 20 Minuten. Aber vorher gucke ich mir noch irgendwie ein
bisschen Twitch Stream an. ASMR Video. Irgendwas, keine Ahnung. Oder gehe ich 22 Uhr, gehe ich pennen.
Schön, dass ihr da gewesen seid. Ich würde mich auch über sehr gescheite Sätze formen. Ich würde
mich natürlich auch sehr über ein Follow freuen, falls ihr öfters hier informiert sein wollt,
wenn der Stream live geht. Und allgemein freue ich mich natürlich immer, wenn die Zahlen ein
bisschen raufgehen. Und ich würde sagen, ja, ich würde sagen, ich hau jetzt ab. Viel gab es ja im
aktuellen Ubuntu nicht zu sehen. Bis dann. Macht's gut.